hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday August 12 2019 what's going
on how are you what's going on what's
going on Oh Billy Oh Billy baby face all
freckled face [ __ ] oh is rapped on the
movie thank you to everybody
Judd Pete Davidson everybody that I
worked with I had an awesome time the
mustache is gone I checked with the
director before I shaved it off I was
like did you check the gate and all the
others [ __ ] you said is that it's the
batch of film good can I can I not be
this guy anymore he's like it's all good
shave it up send it to the Smithsonian
flush it down the toilet whatever the
[ __ ] you want to do it tonight
that's it did anybody watch on Instagram
when he has shaved it off live live
instagramming there and yeah I got the
baby face enough I swear to god man I
look like I'm like 46 years old I think
that's a good thing
you can pull off five years younger than
your age you know if you're 85 I killed
you look like you're 79 80 Wow checked
out it's a good thing it is a good thing
but at bail all right so what's going on
in the world I have my free time back
baby and last night I did a show at the
I want to Foxwoods I always want to say
great woods nice
Foxwoods I did a show there last night
and I had a [ __ ] great time and I was
very excited because I did an hour in 19
minutes and I only did like two bits
from my last hour not saying I had all a
great material but I had a really good
time working it all out and now that I
got the movie behind me I get to do my
favorite [ __ ] thing in the world
which is put together a new hours
stand-up and I am going
that's what I'm gonna be doing I'm gonna
be popping in down the stand comedy club
I haven't been able to get down there
and beautiful club can't wait to get
down there and I have some positive
memories of being down in that club
after all the [ __ ] the horror that
happened this past a couple weeks so
anyway it's gonna be putting it together
and last night I was having a great time
and you know I don't really talk about
politics or anything like that but like
I was just sort of making fun of I was
making fun of Trump but not like you
know those guys it is deliver but I just
thought it was funny that he retweeted
conspiracy theory about Jeffrey Epstein
and I've Steinhauer you say his [ __ ]
name and how he thinks like global
warming is a hoax and just all of this
[ __ ] you know they got the guy the guy
responds to tweets it's like you're the
leader of the free world can you [ __ ]
act like it you know I thought the
lowest and I was choking I was like I
thought the lowest point was gonna be
when like Obama did The Tonight Show
it's like I don't want to see you do it
that'd be on a show that'll book me
you're the [ __ ] threads of it you
gonna come on do [ __ ] ten minutes on
the Russians hope Jimmy calls you over
to the couch it's just like I [ __ ]
hate how did that office has just
because of its it's all been splintered
now and they that they have to like
[ __ ] be on social media so that's all
I was really doing and this guy in the
crowd just goes he goes leave Trump load
[Music]
and then somebody else said I don't know
some other word hoax got out there and
some woman in the crowd goes oh bomber
was a hoax and I just went on this riff
talking about the two of them we're so
[ __ ] dumb that they boat that that
they should [ __ ] just so we could see
what you would make and and then later
on somebody else I don't know I was
teased and I was making fun of Tom Brady
how is a 42 3 4 year old man he ran a
faster 40 than he did when he was 22 or
23 and this made this guy in the balcony
flip out about Tom Brady I was just
talking about all this [ __ ] that I'd
said leading up to that point and I
bring up Tom Brady and that's the thing
that triggers you and I don't know I was
just riffing on how that all of them
should have like a threesome I don't
know it's just said that whole [ __ ]
they think this is
I hope the dumbest time politically I've
ever seen in my [ __ ] life I have
never in my life ever seen [ __ ]
somebody mouth-breathing morons when it
comes to politics where they will not
hold anybody in their party accountable
to anything and if you say anything they
go well the Democrats do this like when
I I came back from the what do you call
it that the [ __ ] gig last night Fox
what's right
I actually I rented a helicopter to fly
up and go do it okay which I never do
[ __ ] like that because it's so [ __ ]
expensive but every once in a while if
it's like inside of an hour you know and
I just do it like once a year or
something like that you know what I mean
like if I have I live in LA if I have a
gig in San Diego I'll fly out and if I
do Vegas I'll fly out but even this time
I'm not flying out because it's just so
it's so much [ __ ] money it's thrown
down the [ __ ] toilet you can't write
it off right and you know I got a kid so
I just in the back of my head I'm like
this is money that I could leave to my
kid and instead I'm doing this [ __ ]
[ __ ] so every once in a while I'll do it
right so I just completely lost my
[ __ ] train of thought there what was
the point of that bill anyway I is just
like a [ __ ] side of like early onset
Alzheimer's I was talking about Polly
people in politics oh that's right so I
went to land
and I was telling the driver he goes you
know he goes how cool was that I go - it
was [ __ ] unbelievable
it was unbelievable was a clear night
and I got to fly you know up the west
side cross Manhattan at about 96th
Street transition transition LaGuardia
500 feet south stanchion Throgs Neck
bridge and then you're [ __ ] out over
Long Island Sound you see New Rochelle
Stamford New Haven then Londonderry you
make a left and then you [ __ ] land at
a helipad you go and do a show I felt
like Elvis how was it it was incredible
then this guy had this software that was
even better than the four flight that I
use that shows you all the planes and
helicopters in your area the direction
they're flying and whether in the
altitude that they're at they will say
in red - 900 or in green plus 1200 so at
that point and and if you do that and
you have flight following okay and
you're 500 feet above the the highest
object in your area at all times you
only have to worry about is if you have
some sort of [ __ ] mechanical problem
with your own [ __ ] helicopter but you
know you gonna be fine it's tremendous
so he was saying he goes do you do that
a lot the driver I go no I never do it
it's too [ __ ] expensive and you know
there's no write-offs I said then Trump
also [ __ ] went off adding all of
these [ __ ] taxes cuz he got pissed
off at Hollywood he took away all our
write-offs and you know what the guy
said he goes what I mean the Democrats
would do that it's like no another
Republican wouldn't have done that
another Republican would has shook it
off this was specifically this guy thing
can you just stop with this [ __ ] it
drives me up the [ __ ] wall
it did that watching people in Hollywood
looking at the Obamas like they were
these saintly [ __ ] people who who
gave the corporation's their [ __ ]
continued the [ __ ] war killed all of
these innocent [ __ ] people with drone
strikes and now they're out on the
speech tour taking all of their [ __ ]
bribe money so they can go out and go
buy a [ __ ] house they're no different
than anybody with the [ __ ] red tie
and I swear to God I can't I just cannot
[ __ ] sit there
and listen to these [ __ ] people who
just sit there I just watched CNN
I just watched Fox News yeah you sound
like it so that brings me to Jeffrey
Epstein Epstein I want to know where
that man is cuz I'm telling you right
now he is not dead yeah take that man is
not dead I don't where he is I actually
you know why couldn't he just be a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and just killed himself
because he didn't want to [ __ ] spend
the rest of his life in jail or I didn't
want to go through the embarrassment of
having a mirror held up to his
piece-of-shit face as to what the [ __ ]
he was doing down on his island huh or
maybe his publicist said well you know
if you kill yourself you don't go
through the trial then people won't hear
all the gory details why couldn't it
just be that why couldn't it just be a
couple of guards who weren't [ __ ]
looking or whatever I don't know this
guy's done I love all these people
though the guy's on 24 hours Jewish side
watch and he somehow kills himself I
mean how is that possible the next time
somebody says that say explain 24 hours
suicide watch what exactly does that
entail you know is there just a guy
sitting at it on it you know looking at
a TV screen you know somebody hands him
a coffee and he never looks at it he
just sets it down next to him and he
sees he's trying to find the coffee cup
with his phone you know accidentally
tips his coffee over the coffee rolls
down into his lap he's screaming and
agony agony but never takes his eye off
the screen what what exactly does 24
hours of surveillance entail you know
doesn't they they turn a camera on the
guy and what they just sitting there
staring at it for [ __ ] 24 hours I
don't [ __ ] know
I know it's really convenient that the
[ __ ] guy died and I'm not saying that
he couldn't have got whacked but when
they just have somebody stab him up in
the yard that usually seems the way it
goes down everybody's like the guy's
been deadly there's not even an autopsy
yet well he just died I don't know I
don't know what happened but my favorite
thing of people who are trying to tie it
into Donald Trump or [ __ ] Bill
Clinton the Clintons had him killed
like the Clintons are like this mob
family you know they're [ __ ]
politicians right they just walk around
blowing people for money that's all they
do
you're horrific Lee underplay paid as a
politician and you got to have [ __ ] a
tuxedo and tap dance shoes your entire
[ __ ] career tap-dancing for these
people who are gonna give you money and
then you're gonna owe them favors and if
you don't do what they want you can't
then someday give a [ __ ] hour-long
speech and get $300,000 from them that's
basically what they all do including the
saintly Obama's you know that's what
they're doing that's what they all
[ __ ] do all right I think my
conspiracy theory is that in the 1960s
the message was sent that if you don't
do what the people who are truly running
the [ __ ] country want you to do
conveniently a crazed lone gunman will
come out of nowhere and take you out
black or white male or female that's
essentially what happened to anybody who
was truly going to affect change in a
way that they did not like it was too
convenient and I think now they don't
even need to whacky anymore they can
just they can just take you out in the
newspapers by just not giving you any
coverage like a Bernie Sanders guy they
can just completely ignore this guy and
how much people liked him and wanted him
in the last election to represent the
Democratic Party they could just
completely ignore it and not give it any
Virgen if they don't give it any
coverage than it didn't happen you know
and I'm not saying that Bertie would
have been better than Hillary or better
than so I'm not saying any of that I'm
just saying that they can kind of steer
you where the [ __ ] they want to go which
is pretty obvious when you get any rules
you deregulate ownership of media it's
why they had it in the beginning and
they got rid of all of that and it's
probably why everybody is just screaming
and yelling now and just blaming one
side or the other at a level that I've
never seen before it's like [ __ ] I
can't even like I mean it's it's like
it's like a trained [ __ ] chimp if you
say to somebody who is a conservative if
you if you go can you believe [ __ ]
Trump said that the view well Obama said
but blah blah blah like what I'm not
[ __ ] talk I didn't say Obama was good
I'm just saying it's not unsettling to
you that a [ __ ] president is
retweeting conspiracy theory think about
that people do you remember if you
listen to this podcast seven eight years
ago when I really got into that [ __ ] how
[ __ ] nuts I sounded how [ __ ] truly
nuts I sounded and I was just a comedian
doing a podcast now you have the [ __ ]
leader of the free world whatever the
[ __ ] that means that's like Michael
Jackson the King of Pop
I mean who gave that guy whose [ __ ]
nickname he did right the President of
the United States is retweeting
conspiracy theory that should [ __ ]
bother everybody nope well look guy with
the blue tie did this re and an end of
discussion and this is why I don't
follow politics because the second
anybody in a conversation than Amin Amin
does not agree with me 100% I just have
to shut down because I have everything
figured out not you
so anyway my Andrew was telling me that
a bunch of you guys sent in your was
we're asking about like this [ __ ] guy
I did not follow the story at all
I was too busy working so I don't have
no idea what happened and once Trump
retweeted the conspiracy theory it
knocked all the conspiracy theory away I
can't seem to find any of the conspiracy
theories all I can find his stories
about Trump retweeting it like watch
this Jeffrey Epps Stein theory let's see
here all right let's see how conspiracy
theories spread after the financers
death Jeffrey Epstein how come okay wait
I think I just found it all right
Trump promotes Epstein Clinton's
conspiracy Trump retweets Epstein theory
Jeffrey's death apparent suicide
inspires new conspiracy theories well
let's read some conspiracy theories run
riot with Trump's help see now right
there I don't want to read that one
because I feel like that's just gonna be
a blue page just [ __ ] on him because
he wears a red tie alright forget the
conspiracy theories I like this person's
here's an op-ed piece here's why it's
likely Jeffrey Epstein killed himself
Epstein
all right the safest bet is that Jeffrey
Epstein died by suicide given the
evidence to date along with data on
suicide among the Taney's in custody
awaiting trial that's the most likely
conclusion to draw pending a ruling on
Epstein's death from the new york city
office of chief medical examiner but
that hasn't stopped a torrent of social
media posts offering elaborate theories
where are they I want to read them
suggesting the accused sex offender was
the target of an orchestrated killing
conjecture has run wild with both
Epstein our hashtag FC murders slash
Clinton body count trending on Twitter
many tweets begin with the preface
assuring the reader I'm not in Kentucky
in two conspiracies but and then they
offer conspiracy theory one theory
places the blame on President Trump in
the US Attorney General William bar
wait a minutes a little close to my name
oh wait am i involved is that my
codename it goes like this powerful
people in control of the Department of
Judges Justice were fearful of what
other politically prominent names
Epstein might give to prosecutors and so
had Epstein murdered in custody staging
it as a suicide purveyors of this
serious note that Epstein was being held
in a federal facility which is part of
the Department of Justice run by Barr
okay now I'm starting to believe and
that the Justice Department is within
the executive branch run by Donald Trump
another equally far-fetched theory
substitutes the Clintons for Trump as
the shadowy powers who ordered a hit on
Epstein technically however this theory
can no longer be dismissed as fringe
because it has been ratified by various
by a very official figure the president
and now I just lost everything because
Los Angeles Times I don't want to read
that please please get rid of this
please close this window thank you on
Saturday as speculation ran rampant
Trump retweeted a post from the comedian
Terrence Williams who wrote died of
suicide on 24/7 suicide watch yeah right
how does that happen
Jeffrey Epstein had information on Bill
Clinton and now he's dead Trump's tweets
our official statements of the White
House which means that this fringe
theory is no longer fringe yeah this is
just going off the [ __ ] rails here I
don't know what happened to this guy I
just hope whoever he [ __ ] did [ __ ] to
can get help and somehow find love and
forget what the [ __ ] happened to him
what you that that guy did to him which
of course you can't in other than that
whatever one cares he's a piece of [ __ ]
and he's [ __ ] dead all right other
than that what are you gonna go nuts you
think you're gonna scream about it on
Twitter and then they're gonna be
alright you got us we killed him we
killed him okay because I was down there
and I was doing I was playing hopscotch
with a five-year-old or whatever the
[ __ ] it is those people are doing I
didn't want to know what the [ __ ]
they're doing that's other people's job
to go down that [ __ ]
don't you hate when you on clickbait
when you can never find the woman that's
in the picture I mean they shown this
absolutely incredible look at woman and
then I got to go through a hundred in
one slides to get to her
101 slides
okay flash player I know not to [ __ ]
click on that oh they're gonna try to
fish me anytime they say you need to
update your Flash Player I don't I don't
[ __ ] do that until my videos won't
work all right let's get out of this
stupid [ __ ] conspiracy theory good
witness that guy I'm glad he's [ __ ]
dead
anyway let's see here where am i okay
please announce San Diego this Thursday
Jason lawhead is recording his album at
the Comedy Store in La Jolla at 8 p.m. 8
p.m. show $10 tickets Jason law had
Rosebowl tailgate legend is recording
his album at the Comedy Store in La
Jolla this Thursday 8 p.m. show $10
tickets alright let's get into some fun
[ __ ] bump up doo doo doo doo doo doo doo
doo doo the football season a preseason
anyways has officially started Patriots
played on Thursday I guess they look
good I have no idea what how much weight
do you put on these [ __ ] preseason
games and I guess they're they're out
here enjoy Z who are they playing let's
see Patriots preseason schedule who's
gonna replace Rob Gronkowski Patriots
preseason schedule what do we got here
Saturday or they got the Giants on the
29th they always play the Giants in the
preseason you notice that [ __ ] every
Scout they're close by I don't know
Panthers Patriots that's all preseason
so we got the Titans on say Thursday the
22nd we got the Panthers and then we got
the 29th
which i think is another Thursday game
and then it's the [ __ ] football
season let's see what does the Patriots
schedule look like how do you even tell
like who's good anymore
in football with all the parity all
right so here's our schedule we open
Sunday night with the Pittsburgh
Steelers
then we got the Dolphins so we're at
home against the Steelers then we're at
the dolphin somebody got the Jets then
we're at the bills then we're at the
Redskins I'm going to that game baby
then Thursday night we got the Giants at
home against the Giants oh we're playing
that division so which means we got the
Cowboys this year we're uh we're gonna
get a lot of [ __ ] this year or not of
road games huh we're at the Eagles G
what game are they gonna bring up at the
New York Jets Cleveland Browns at the
Baltimore Ravens then we're at the
Eagles then we got a home game against
the Cowboys then we're at the Texans
home game against the cheap she got to
go to that game got to get tickets to
that game think about that one Patrick
mahomes when he's young Tom Brady on his
way out what a great game to say that
you went to you know that'd be like if a
young Joe Montana played against an old
[ __ ] in Joe Namath and you went to the
game at the Cincinnati Bengals then we
got the Buffalo Bills and we got the
Miami Dolphins and guess what I have
this year [ __ ] people I have all
kinds of free time because all I'm doing
stand-up in my podcast for the rest of
the year which means I'm going to watch
every single [ __ ] second of the
Patriots season I'll give a [ __ ] if they
go on 16 you know I don't give a [ __ ] I
watch it every single one of these and I
have no idea this this seems like a
tough schedule to me I think a lot of
these teams are going to be good
dolphins always play as tough we get the
two Jet's games out of the way early we
always seem to split with them I wasn't
that crazy we're playing
the Jets twice and the Giants once three
games against New York two out of three
are in Boston or in Foxborough he's a
daddy interesting all right and we play
in the NFC East and our road games are
at Washington at Philly and then we play
in the the central I guess man if you're
ever gonna do some road trips this year
for a Patriots schedule this is pretty
easy if you live in and around Boston
all right at Miami's far but at Buffalo
at Washington at New York at Baltimore
at Philly at Houston that's a little bit
of a ride at Cincinnati dude if you were
ever gonna go to all [ __ ] Patriots
games in one year this is the year to do
it you can do every game by car every
game is a [ __ ] road you could you know
it's a it's a haul but you could do it
right you could do it every single one
except for a Houston in Miami that's it
Miami's not a bad flight that's great I
would just say this if you go into the
the you know some of these like Buffalo
Philly
you know the Ravens at home yeah you got
to watch yourself I'd be careful with
wearing like the [ __ ] Patriots gear
some of those [ __ ] idiots out there
taking out their childhoods on people
who [ __ ] just go into a goddamn game
alright let's do some of the reads here
this week alright where are we the [ __ ]
am i doing here
alright good boys all I can't wait to
see this movie all right what if the
guys who made some of the most
outrageous r-rated comedies like
Superbad and sausage party decided to
make an r-rated comedy starring
twelve-year-old boys well they did and
it's the hilarious new movie called good
boys it follows three innocent sixth
graders as they skip school one day to
do whatever it takes to learn how to
kiss before their first middle-school
party the thing is they get themselves
into a ton of internal inappropriate and
r-rated
situations along the way early audiences
and critics have been raving about good
boys saying that you'll laugh for 90
minutes straight they're calling it
delightfully inappropriate wildly
raunchy and undeniably sweet don't
forget to go see good boys in theaters
August 16th oh look at that I'm gonna
check that out when I get back to LA I'm
getting behind in the movies I still
haven't seen the Tarantino one yet
either
anybody know a good place to see it in
LA is it's still shown at one of those
70-millimeter places because I want to
see it like that if I can if I still can
all right simply safe everybody on
average it takes police 45 minutes to
respond to a home security alarm when a
home security system is triggered a lot
of time police assume it's a false alarm
and the call goes to the bottom of the
list but not with simply safe home
security simply safe has video
verification technology which helps
police get on the scene up to 3.5 times
faster they can visually confirm that a
break-in is happening and let the police
know making their average police
response time just seven minutes do they
really need to tell these [ __ ]
criminals how much time they have I mean
a [ __ ] alarm goes off you got a good
ten minutes most cops were just they're
all loaded for bear simply safe also
protects every door window and room with
24/7 professional monitoring there's no
contract hidden fees or fine print this
system has won a ton of awards from CNET
to New York Times to wirecutter Oh New
York Times is wire cutter
around-the-clock monitoring starts at
just 15 dollars a month and for my
listeners simply safe has a huge deal
going on right now go to simply safe
bird comm and get free shipping and a
month money-back guarantee that's simply
safe bird comm simply safe bird comm all
right look who's back old zip curta
hiring used to be hard multiple job site
stacks of resumes a confusing review
process plus plus today hiring can be
easy and you only have to go to one
place to get it done sip clear do.com
slash Birds epic Reuters sent
job out to over 100 of the web's leading
job boards but they don't stop there
with their powerful matching
technologies it scans thousands of
resumes to find people with the right
experience and invites them to apply to
your job resume apply to your job sorry
as applications come in zip analyzes
each one and spotlights the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match zip recruit ISM is so effective
that four out of five employers who post
on zip get a quality candidate through
the site within the first day and right
now my listeners can try zip recruiter
for free at this exclusive web address
zi PR e CR UI ter comm / / that zip
recruiter comm / / zip we clear dot-com
/ / zip recruit the smartest way to hire
oh look who it is stamps.com everybody
no one really has time to go to the post
office you're busy who's got time for
all that traffic oh the parking lugging
all your mail and postage packages sorry
it's a real hassle man that's why you
need stamps calm one of the most popular
time-saving tools for small businesses
stamps calm eliminates trips to the post
office and saves you money and discounts
with discounts sorry that you can't even
get it to post office stamps calm brings
all the amazing services of the u.s.
post office right to your computer
whether you're a small office sending
invoices an online seller shipping out
products or even a warehouse sending
thousands of packages today stamps calm
can handle it all with ease simply use
your computer to print official US
postage 24/7 for any letter any package
any class of mail any way you want to
send once your mail is ready just hand
it to your mail carrier or prop it drop
it in the mailbox it's that simple with
stamp just calm you get five cents off
every first-class stamp and up to 40%
off Priority Mail not to mention it's a
fraction of the cost of those
offensive postage meters stamps.com is a
no-brainer saving you time and money
it's no wonder over 700 thousand small
businesses already used stamps calm
right now my listeners get a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
without any long-term commitment just go
to stamps comm click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in
bur that stamps.com enter bur alrighty
then I watched a couple of movies by the
way at the after party for the for the
movie we were we were doing a bunch of
Rodney jokes throughout so we watched
easy money and we watched back-to-school
I had not seen easy money and so long
and Taylor Negron and Joe Pesci is
hilarious in it and you look at [ __ ]
Roddy that guy cannot stand [ __ ]
still the whole time he's sitting there
in like back-to-school when they come
when they have his his point of view and
Sam kinnison's walking up the stairs to
come to him you see him sitting if you
look at his left leg he has like [ __ ]
restless leg syndrome just one of the
greatest [ __ ] comedians of all time
they just watching back to school with
so like his movies they don't even make
sense like they basically like with
scripts how it works is you know
technically is the first 10 pages 10
pages in you're supposed to have that
[ __ ] moment it's like alright this is
what we need to do this is what we have
to accomplish Act one supposed to end
somewhere around 25 30 pages act 2 about
60 pages in and then you wrap it up with
act 3 alright and you done 90 100 pages
dude that's [ __ ] easy money they
don't get through the first 10 pages
until 40 minutes into the [ __ ] movie
it's just all jokes about what a [ __ ]
degenerate he is for 40 [ __ ] minutes
and it's hilarious and somehow the movie
still works and then it back to school
that one that one doesn't get
it's like all fat jokes he runs like a
big and tall the whole thing is just fat
jokes so [ __ ] 18 minutes before they
get into where the hell they want to be
but we had a great time watch I highly
recommend watching uh easy money just as
far as like and back to school just as
far as just like jokes you could just
never do anymore and also Burt Young's
and that one he's one of my favorite
actors of all time and if you notice in
the end he's actually holding hands with
a freshman like they're like
boyfriend/girlfriend now cuz he was like
Rodney's chauffeur you know if you ever
did jokes like that are they advocating
a 60 year old guy going out with an
eighteen year old I mean what are we
watching here you know pissed me off the
other day and in general this [ __ ]
annoys the [ __ ] out of me I am so sick
of people having advice on their [ __ ]
clothes
like somebody was walking down the
street I'm look at this person they had
do what you love on their t-shirt I just
want to be like you bought that please
tell me like I don't know yeah there was
a house fire and somebody just gave you
a free t-shirt and that's what the [ __ ]
it was not that I want your house to
burn down do what you love like you you
looked in your [ __ ] little sh t shirt
drawing you're like yeah I'm gonna share
this with the world first of all do what
you love is pretty mainstream advice
right and I feel like like your life has
to be like at a pretty [ __ ] you're
gonna be operating in a pretty high
level I do what I love I would never
walk down the street with the shirt that
says do what you love because I want
immediately Philly an [ __ ] like what
oh I got everything figured out I mean
look at me I do what I love for a living
and I still get annoyed at [ __ ]
people wearing t-shirts that has stuff
on it words on it I still give a [ __ ] so
right there I'm out I'm not qualified to
give [ __ ] people advice
I guess if you're a motivational speaker
and you're on the way to one of your
speakings and you do and you don't want
to change into your costume you're just
gonna come right in there be like all
right people what are we here for what
are we here to learn and you point to
your t-shirt we're gotta do we love
that's right Jesus wants you to do what
you love he wants you to get an island
and [ __ ] children and then kill yourself
in his cell do what you love and do what
you love is really open-ended especially
when you're walking around New York City
because you can be [ __ ] to saying that
to a mass murdering psycho I mean that's
a [ __ ] sketch right there right do
what you love you have a guy sitting and
if I don't shoot sketches I just say
them on the podcast all right you got a
guy sitting in a [ __ ] diner looking
shifty but sort of said and then oh this
beautiful woman walks by with a do what
you laddus that make her beautiful
because then you feel bad for a a
feminist looking woman right now yeah go
there's this somebody that nobody cares
if they die so you have like a feminist
woman walking by right the [ __ ] hairy
armpits in the goddamn you know [ __ ]
Janeane Garofalo glasses right not not
attacking her but just the first person
I thought I'll let me pick somebody else
Superman glasses Clark Kent right
walking down the [ __ ] Street and he
sit there in the diner and then she the
person has do what you love on the
t-shirt and then you just see it really
affects them and the person gets up and
starts walking behind the person with
the do what you love and you're like oh
whoa I was getting kind of weird the
woman turns the corner he [ __ ] knocks
her over the head and throws it a trunk
of his car right and then that's his
first victim and the name of this short
is do what you love sorry I don't know
what just do what you love it's just
like I just want to be like I just want
to be I just don't do that public but I
just want to walk up to the person to be
like can I ask you a question just like
like how would how are you qualified to
give the world
vice just what do you what are you doing
in your life like what what do you do
with your life because I do what I love
and I would never be so [ __ ] arrogant
as to wear that goddamn t-shirt
remember that [ __ ] thing that's
stupid t-shirt mean people suck
there was just such a [ __ ]
self-serving t-shirt and you also making
yourself a victim and he's like what are
you your urine you're a nice person with
a [ __ ] who [ __ ] vetted you won one of
these [ __ ] broads on these awards
shows giving guys lectures it's like
when does the lecture end [ __ ]
sitting there acting like all of us took
our dicks out at work do you know
[ __ ] insane you gotta be to take out
your member at work I always want to be
to to the to the woman be like well who
vetted you whoever said you were a nice
[ __ ] person you never threw your
phone at one of your assistants eyelids
let's [ __ ] look into your past I
don't know is that a dumb thing to get
upset about I'm just seeing them more
and more I guess I guess as the world
gets sadder and sadder and more and more
depressing because everybody's on
[ __ ] social media which the worst
thing I did not remember like a month
ago I was reading that Ken Stabler
autobiography and I just put my phone
down I just automatically I was in a
better mood because I wasn't looking at
that [ __ ] but there are a few that do
make me laugh though I'm not saying
social media is all bad crime faces
obviously I was told you guys about that
that's a great one and then I was
following this other one I forget what
the name of it was it was just people
doing dumb things and this poor bastard
was in a band and it was like towards
the end of the concert and they were
going nuts in front of this big crowd
and he was running with his guitar and
he went to look leap
on to his amplifier or something and he
just totally lost his footing he
basically leaped up in the air he gave
himself a suplex and landed on the
corner not even flush he landed on the
corner of one of the cabinets I can't
believe it didn't come out the front of
his shirt and he just took it and stood
back up and just ran up to the
microphone to do the background vocals I
mean he kept the show going it was it
was pretty [ __ ] amazing I do like
looking at [ __ ] like that but uh
somebody on the movie gave me a book on
Sonny Liston which I'm gonna [ __ ]
start reading today because I have the
whole day to myself well that the whole
day to myself I'm gonna play with my kid
too
but uh but that's not work cuz I'm doing
what I love owning you know what I'm
gonna start having inspirational
t-shirts that just annoy people just
have a t-shirt that just says you know
tell that [ __ ] to shut up and then when
you get confronted you'd be like what
all the oh yeah you know what that's
just laundry day I wanted at a carnival
I think they give that away to Carnival
yeah well you got to beat people in a
game first I think was the water pistol
game I want to have my inspirational
t-shirts how about guess what you're a
[ __ ] too
don't give me advice on your t-shirt but
you guys buy any of these I don't get
involved in the t-shirt business you
know I mean cuz then it's like where was
the t-shirt made all right and to make
it cost effective the only way to do it
it seems to be some sort of [ __ ]
sweatshop labor is that what it is bill
is that what the whole world is to you I
don't know maybe that's why there are
happy t-shirts out there bill because
there's people like you walking around
in the world all right hang on one
second here we go here we go let's read
some [ __ ] letters for the week here
helping educators
hey Billy back to school i watch that
hey the back to school okay
oh my favorite line two favorite lines
in easy money both Joe Pesci now get out
of here you half a [ __ ] before I give
you a slap and he was also talking about
taking the boat back from LA how to get
to New York and he said you know he
explains the whole route and then he
goes in in English when he talks about
getting to New York he goes we go by
that broad with the green dress and
we're back all right
thought I'd bring this to your attention
since you've mentioned wanting to help
schools in need yeah public schools I
completely failed with that because it
was all this I couldn't just give money
to that school it seemed to have to go
into some giant fund and I would then
lose control as to like where that money
would go to many schools are back in
session this week which means thousands
of teachers are having to buy important
classroom supplies with their own money
the Twitter page at support underscore
at each weight underscore a underscore
teach started a movement called clear
the list and is currently retweeting
teachers Amazon wish lists from across
the country each teacher's list as a
little blurb about what subject they
teach and what district they are in
there are hundreds to scroll through but
even a couple little things - one or two
people make a difference hope you and
everyone listening can help thank you
well I also hope that it's legit and
also what what the [ __ ] are we doing
with our country that they don't have
money for this it's [ __ ] just you know
I just don't understand how how people
buy into the [ __ ] rhetoric of
politicians when they're clearly just
for helping themselves out clearly just
helping out rich people you know like
what Jon Stewart had to do the level of
shame he had to bring for them to
finally give firefighters who went down
to the World Trade Center
to help clean up and look for their
buddies and other victims what he had to
do to finally get him to help him out
almost 20 [ __ ] years later you know
well they'll just give corporations
endless amounts of [ __ ] money for
these all these goddamn [ __ ] wars
just I don't know I don't know how you
stay positive about it but I guess it's
up to us as citizens to do something
positive you know what I'll look into
that how's she looking at that right now
let's see what this is about I really
hope this is legit all right what the
[ __ ] was it here help underscore support
underscore at support underscore all
right I'm never gonna remember this at
support underscore a underscore teacher
let's see where this gets me clear the
list hashtag on Twitter all right clear
the list let's see if I can let's see if
I can vet this clear clear the list do
what you love
clear the list legitimacy here we go and
that took me know where you win
sanctions I just you know I just suck at
the Internet all right I hope this is
real nope it's real I just wish I knew a
specific teacher okay and they'd be like
these are the supplies I need for my
classroom and then I could buy the
supplies go into the classroom and hand
it out to the kids this is how jaded I
am because back in the day I helped did
one of the way I [ __ ] gave all this
money to one of those uh you know troops
that got wounded and [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] to help that out and turn out
the [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] family was
taken most of the money all right
anyway season and is there any teachers
listening here in the loss
angeles-area there we go there we go
los angeles-area I want to be back out
there this week what supplies do you
need specifically we're not gonna send
you the money we're gonna go out and buy
the actual [ __ ] and I'm gonna come down
there oh-ho-oh with a big [ __ ] white
beard I'm gonna hand it out to everybody
how about that can I do that so then I
know that you're not doing that to
[ __ ] you know build a drum room in
your house
all right seasons of the year problem hi
Bill I'm a longtime podcast listener and
an overall fan of your art in general
well thank you very much your
performance here in Amsterdam in May was
one of the highlights of my spring and
for this I want to say a huge thank you
well thank you I had a great time going
over there however oh Jesus I have a
problem with your view on seasons of the
year you keep saying that summer ends on
September 23rd like it's some sort of
universal truth which it is not the
summer you're talking about is an
astronomical summer which is based on
equinoxes and solises all right I'm
already gonna just give in to this
argument because I don't really talking
about and if you are the one who can't
pronounce those words or tell off the
top of your head what when those happens
you should go [ __ ] yourself and stick to
the simple definition which is a
meteorology meteorology meteorological I
gotta get this word meaty or logical
summer it starts on June 1st and ends
June 31st it makes more sense since it
describes seasons the way they make
sense to us
summer is warm winter is cold etc so
please stop pretending like you're that
medieval astronomer wait a minute with
global warming it's warm into [ __ ]
October alright you know what I've had
enough of your [ __ ] if you stopped like
the [ __ ] two paragraphs all right
we'll explain to me I know that the
summer everyone's you know it switches
around like
in Easter all right now I got to look
these [ __ ] words up here equinoxes
you know what I was listening and then
you just we just went a little too
[ __ ] hard Equinox
[ __ ] hilarious hotel gym definition
the time or date twice each year at
which the Sun crosses the celestial
equator and I go look up something else
I know what the Equator is what's the
celestial equator when day and night are
of equal length okay
September 22nd and March 20th okay
solstices all right let's look this up
I remember memorizing these at some
point in my my youth okay solstices
definition so don't quiet it got when I
try to learn something either of the two
times in the year the summer solstice
and the winter solstice when the Sun
reaches its highest or lowest point in
the sky marked by the longest and
shortest days okay so all right let me
try to wrap my head around this so this
one summer is just saying it's June July
in August because that's what it is
every year when it's just normally the
hottest time and then to make it more
precise as you figure out where the
earth is going around the Sun and you
take out your little [ __ ] what do you
protractor is that how you figure it out
what's the longest day and what's the
shortest day when the sun's gonna reach
its highest point in its lowest point so
I imagine the highest point is the
hottest day of the year versus the
lowest point and then you stick that the
highest point and then you have a
certain amount of days before it after
that's peak summer is that what it is
can somebody help me out I feel scared
all right it starts on June 1st and ends
the August 31st it
more sense since its described the
season alright but in mine it says the
21st to the 23rd so what is that day
so stop pretending like you're the
medieval astronomer that was burned
alive and stick to the normal definition
of the season we have or at least give a
disclaimer that you are talking about
seasons the way they were described in
the 1400s warm regards to your family
and go [ __ ] yourself buddy I never said
I knew any of that [ __ ] I'm just saying
that this year it said summer began in
June 21st and ended on September 23rd I
conveyed that information and now you're
yelling at me like I [ __ ] said it I
repeated it jesus [ __ ] christ and all
you did was [ __ ] move it up a few
days instead of saying June 21st you
said June 1st and yours ends the 31st
instead of the 23rd so isn't that the
same amount of [ __ ] days roughly I
think we're saying the same goddamn
thing here all I'm saying is you can
keep your [ __ ] boat in the water
until the beginning of October with
global warming and everybody's oh where
the [ __ ] did the summer go take a summer
vacation and [ __ ] September and [ __ ]
you and your [ __ ] equinoxes and your
[ __ ] solstice you can still [ __ ]
put a boat in the goddamn water and
water-ski now in September that's all
I'm saying and do it while the kids are
at school that's great you got a [ __ ]
professional babysitter all I was trying
to do sir is make people happy that's
all I was doing I never claimed that I
was a [ __ ] scientist they've never
heard me read out loud you'd understand
but I got to give you this sir you
really know what you're talking about
our ma'am and you now have to be
fascinated with this [ __ ] information
and this is the thing what I actually if
I actually take the time to figure out
what the [ __ ] this means because I do
find this fascinating and I have a
tremendously poor science background
and I'm not the smartest guy if I do
figure out what it means that no [ __ ]
point will I ever explain it to somebody
on a [ __ ] t-shirt walking down the
street alright so there in the end I
still made myself to hero so why don't
you go [ __ ] yourself
alright Vietnam really oh geez I'm just
getting this [ __ ] I'm getting killed
here Vietnam was a [ __ ] show and was a
totally stupid war villagers were killed
and countless others suffered for no
reason and you are an idiot when it
comes to politics okay wait a minute
wait a minute this do you see how this
person just jump I don't know what this
[ __ ] person is even talking about
just jumped like whatever I said so
pissed them off that they just fired off
this email like when they were listening
to this podcast I was talking to them I
don't know what you're talking about
here sir or ma'am and you were an idiot
when it comes to politics
yeah I've admitted that because the
second you decide to make a point you
backhand your own [ __ ] point by
[ __ ] on the point you just made yeah
that's called seeing both sides of the
story and also admitting that you don't
have nearly enough information to make
it an informed point the same as you you
haven't made one point here you're just
insulting me you have no [ __ ] balls
great point
you're a fence dancer great expression
and a complete wishy-washy doofus I love
that you said [ __ ] balls and then
also used the word doofus I can't tell
if you're a clean comic or a [ __ ]
work in the nasty show here the 60s was
a great time in American history for
social change I would have been with the
students bootlicker all right first of
all did you okay and I know he talked
did you watch the documentary before you
had your [ __ ] little meltdown temper
tantrum all right you would have been
with the students that just walked into
town and smashed up a bunch of
storefront windows of mom-and-pop stores
all these innocent people who didn't
start the war
you know Vietnam was a [ __ ] show as
opposed to what what's going on now
isn't a [ __ ] show a never-ending war
with no [ __ ] exit strategy that's
bankrupting the country that's not a
[ __ ] show
I thought Vietnam was a [ __ ] show and a
totally stupid war you just [ __ ]
repeated yourself all right ok all right
you know what I'm gonna act like you're
not as dumb as the way that reads and
that you I made you very emotional
listen I don't care how much I don't
agree with what our government is doing
at any given point in history at no
point
would I ever attack somebody else's
storefront you know even if the person
disagreed with me and had a sign in
there saying I support the exact
opposite of what you do I wouldn't throw
a brick through their [ __ ] window
because it doesn't prove anything it
doesn't do anything I'm causing them
harm and all I'm doing is just creating
a bigger distance between me and this
other person that I want to hear and
understand my opinion all right is that
wishy-washy to you what are you a real
man because you just went on this little
[ __ ] temper tantrum you're acting
like a [ __ ] five-year-old which I
also do all the [ __ ] time does that
make me wish you washy cuz I owned up to
that I actually do what the [ __ ] you do
to or does it make you means it make you
maybe sit for half a second and think
like oh you know what maybe I do need to
calm down maybe I should pick a side of
the [ __ ] fence we need to decide to
curse or say Jiminy Cricket and
wishy-washy
alright insecurity alright let's see
let's see if we go three for three bill
getting trashed here hey Bill I'm a
twenty-year-old college guy 20 year old
guy in college and in a relationship
with the love of my life congratulations
she's perfect for me in every way and
the moment I met her I knew I was going
to make her my wife well there you go we
have said that we are each other's soul
mate I'm a crazy person with a lot of
insecurities and one in particular was
that I was a virgin until I met her
she was not and always she was not and
always said her last relationship was
nothing but sexual it was embarrassing
because I had never had sex with anyone
else and I felt like a wimp
he got a little bit of a late start
you're only 20 dude you know the 40 year
old virgin and now you're crushing it
good for you and not like a man at all
because I hadn't even kissed a woman
before and I always compare myself to
her ex in terms of him as a boyfriend
and in the bedroom even and even if I
measure up all right first of all let
that [ __ ] go all right that's all in
your head that's not in her head and
that's a great way to talk yourself out
of this great relationship she always
tells me I'm the best she's ever had and
she wishes she could take back wait a
second she always tells me I'm the best
she ever had and that she wishes she
could take it back but I still can't get
the image out of my head and it doesn't
help that I asked and she told me that
he had a bigger dick Oh God
I don't want to drive her away I love
her and never want to lose her would
really appreciate the advice why do guys
ask that question
love the podcasts your stand-up efforts
for family can't wait for season four
come up - I'm not gonna say where you're
from thank you and go [ __ ] yourself any
advice yeah I don't know what to do here
for you buddy you opened Pandora's box
and that bigger dick flew out and you're
just gonna have to get past it
all right that's it
you asked she wishes she could take it
back you know I don't know here's the
thing about women though all right they
love for different reasons okay
okay as big as that guy's dick was that
didn't work out all right so that's in
the [ __ ] past and you know I don't
know they fall in I don't women in
general fall in love for the right
[ __ ] reasons okay they don't fall in
love with a dick all right they fall in
love because of the chemistry you have
the stuff that you're doing for they see
that you're gonna be a great father and
all that type of [ __ ] you're basically
crushing it you're destroying this other
guy had the other than the size of your
dick I mean he's got you beat in that
area okay but there's a lot of times a
team is more talented on paper and then
the other team because they play as a
team wins so you just got to look at
yourself like that all right you're the
underdog here when you're gonna somehow
come away with the victory and they're
gonna give they gonna make a 34:30 about
you I don't know I don't know what to do
like I never I never had a problem with
that [ __ ] to be honest with you so I
have a little difficulty like you know I
mean she's probably also been with a guy
that had a smaller dick I mean you're
somewhere in the middle you got a
regular dick just nothing wrong with
that it's nothing wrong with a mid-sized
car you know it's not wrong with that
all right I gotta be honest that would
not bother me okay having a bigger dick
all right he's jackhammering away and
all that [ __ ] the thing about guys with
bigger dicks is a lot of times that that
you know that's all they could dope they
got the big [ __ ] dick and they just
sort of bang away all right but there's
all other levels that you could bring
this all different you know okay he's
going Blake Griffin he's just dunking on
people you can have a turnaround jumper
you could [ __ ] it you could have a good
transition game you could play good
defense you can go downtown you know you
can up your [ __ ] game you know
there's role-playing there's all kinds
of [ __ ] you can do [ __ ] that she maybe
didn't do with this other guy but no
matter what you're just gonna have to
take that [ __ ] loss and this is one
of the hardest things I've ever had to
do no pun intended to try to talk you
out of the fact that this other guy too
big
there's nothing you can [ __ ] do about
gives a [ __ ] yes he did all right great
are you funnier are you a better cook
she loves you she's the love of your
life
there you go oh here's what you learned
don't ask that [ __ ] question
don't ask a question that you're not
gonna want to hear the answer to all
right but my advice to you is do not
sabotage that [ __ ] relationship over
that [ __ ] and here's another thing
to do not [ __ ] mope about it in front
of her cuz that's gonna turn her off
alright and she'll [ __ ] go back to
the big dick guy alright alright this is
the thing I wouldn't don't even bring it
up alright let that big dick just roll
right off your back alright that's it
okay overrated underrated Jesus Christ
alright underrated reading you're
absolutely right reading books actually
makes you smarter it's been proven and
now I can say I'm proof the better
quality writing you read the better you
are at organizing thoughts
I've been reading before bed for the
last year and I sleep better than ever
that's right you do I learned that
lesson and I forgot it I got to get back
to it
I wake up with more energy because
that's the last thing on my mind because
the last thing on my mind wasn't some
[ __ ] from work that bothers me even
though it won't matter in six months or
I'm watching TV falling asleep with
bright lights flashing in my face that
is true what a great underrated for the
week thank you sir or ma'am overrated
putting people on pedestals next time
someone tells you how great someone else
is make sure it's because they're
constantly changing the lives of
everyone around them for the better or
they cured cancer I'm tired of hearing
about how great someone is when all they
do is stand wave and smile this by
default includes almost every politician
ever
alright good overrated underrated here's
another one
summertime blowies hey there balmy
bagged bill I just wanted to take a
moment to
nice all the brave men and women that
suck dick in the summertime no Jesus it
has been real hot here in Colorado and
this morning and this morning
and took my unit out to do my business
okay I can this is like okay
it's been real hot here in Colorado and
this morning and this morning and took
my unit out to do my business do do you
understand the way you wrote that I
thought you were like you know you were
in the army or something you took your
[ __ ] platoon out or something
no it's been real hot here in Colorado
including this morning new sentence took
my unit out to do my business and I
could not believe the smell coming from
my taint area god bless these troopers
we love you go [ __ ] yourself
also not a fan of your podcast comedy or
f is for family like the mustache thumb
okay
Jesus I'm not a fan of your grammar
there buddy
Jesus Christ alright evidently people
got smelly junk that's another thing I
don't understand a stinky crotch area I
just I don't I don't have that [ __ ]
problem take a shower and that I'm good
people have got to [ __ ] it through all
kinds of talcum powder I thank God I'm
not a sweater
all right yo Wild Bill big [ __ ] I
worked at a cigar shop in Kansas City
for five years and gained a decent
knowledge of cigars here are my top
three oh I love it
a padrone anniversary anniversary Oh
either 1926 or 1964 series Ashton v SG /
ESG virgin / a state son grown Leflore
Leggero l 300 parentheses l 400 / L 500
etc depending on size isn't sold in the
wrapper these are all son grown which I
found is as good if not better than a
Cuban
a fraction of the cost I don't know
about better than a Cuban a real one
come through Kansas City and I'll be the
first to buy tickets Godspeed alright
well there you go there's some cigar
advice okay there you go that's the
podcast for this week god bless all of
you
alright and if we've learned anything on
this podcast please for the love of God
no matter if you're a lefty or a righty
if someone has legitimate criticism of
your political party just take it you
know because then that will make the
other person open to some of your
criticism and maybe both can [ __ ]
learn says something all right
and then number two if you're with a
woman and she's been with other men
don't ask if anyone had a bigger dick
than you when you're standing there with
the mid-size car all right
somebody's gonna pull up with the
Caprice Classic and then it's gonna make
you feel bad about your Ford Fairmont be
happy with what you have and be happy
that you know got a Chevy Chevette there
you go that's it all right go [ __ ]
yourselves and I'll check in on you on
Thursday